hello I'm right Alicia and I'm left
Alicia and this Fandango Geary Movie
Guide almost hello everyone I have three
great movies to tell you about today
let's start with Christine Oh Stephen
King no but just as haunting baby and
get us some footage of the chickens
having sex so people can see how the
eggs are really made what is this what
are you doing I've just been thinking a
lot about your idea sensationalizing the
news Christine tells the true story of
the final few days of Christine Chubbuck
she's the journalist who killed herself
live on air during a news broadcast in
1974 if you see her starting out pretty
optimistic and then slowly becoming more
and more disillusioned as she realizes
that the network is going for more
sensationalized gruesome stuff than her
in-depth local reports if it bleeds it
leads
correct other Alicia this is one of
those movies where you know where it's
going to end so the whole film is
unsettling and tense as you go towards
that inevitable conclusion people I'm
gonna slap a big awards watch over this
one for Rebecca Hall because even though
it's a small film and it might not be
able to compete when it comes to Oscar
campaigning with some of the other
bigger films I think she definitely
deserves an Oscar nomination third
completely inhabiting this role a
television first
and now onto something like not really
but this is my pick of the week tower as
you can tell from that clip tower is a
documentary unlike any other it tells
the true story of the first mass school
shooting in Austin Texas and because
this is one of the first no one knew
what was going on there was so much
confusion but as with all tragic
situations unlikely heroes emerged and
everyday people found strength within
themselves sounds quite inspiring it is
Alicia you were correct the way Keith
Maitland weaves in archival footage with
animation of what happens plus
interviews makes this an absorbing and
fascinating film experience see this in
cinemas way can I just remember
just thinking those both look great but
what's our on home entertainment this
weekend excellent question and it's a
goodie
what we created here may be unique in
existence we created paradise captain
fantastic is a film you probably would
have heard of if you follow me on
Twitter because I've been going on about
this film since January I saw it at
Sundance and again I can film so nice
she watched it twice you could say that
by the way this is what happens when
Fandango says I can do anything I want
with my show she's great I love her
Viggo Mortensen's stars as a father who
is raising his kids outside of society
in the woods they're highly intelligent
they're very skilled but he realizes
when he has to take them back into the
modern world that they don't know how to
cope with everyday society or talk to
other teenagers right now this is your
first real test remember your training
they have hotdogs what's Cola poison
water the reason why I love this movie
so much is that it really makes you
think and it doesn't preach to you you
know it shows both sides of this living
in society living out of society and the
pros and cons within it it's also
energetic funny and very very touching
even if they make it through whatever it
is you're doing to them they're gonna be
totally unprepared for the real world
and I happen to think the opposite is
true it's a childhood view if I wanted
to hit you I would have hit you
so to recap and let's try and do this
one together and really test out my
editing skills in theaters Christine
haunting incredible performance by
Rebecca Hall tower a powerful moving
documentary and at home
captain fantastic it'll make you laugh
it'll make you cry and I'll make you
think that's it for this episode of
Fandango indie movie guide let me know
below which movies you like what you've
seen lately and don't forget you can
follow me on Twitter
I'm Alicia Malone and I'm also Alicia
Malone right